coffee on a Tuesday and blocks ever
so today I want to talk about the
greatest writer that ever lived now
maybe you know or maybe you don't know
but Roland Emmerich's new movie
anonymous hits theaters this Friday we
all know William Shakespeare the most
famous author of all time writer of 37
plays 154 sonnets several epic poem and
why we are here today but what if I told
you Shakespeare never wrote a single
word the movie is meant to explore the
theory that William Shakespeare the
average man from Stratford did not
actually write any poems or play now
conspiracy theories like this aren't new
but it may be important to note that not
a single person doubted Shakespeare
until about 150 years after his death in
1769 Herbert Lawrence publishes a book
called the life and adventures of common
sense in it he suggests that the culprit
might be in fact Francis Bacon a
experiment it as a degenerate and a
thief steals from the character called
wisdom who is the father of common sense
and wisdom is meant to be big amongst my
father's baggage he presently cast his
eye upon a commonplace book in which was
contain an infinite variety of modes and
forms to express all the different
sentiments of the human mind but this
allegation is forgotten in its time and
is it revived until Delia bacon no
relation is it the proper treatment in
her 582 page book the philosophy of the
plays of Shakespeare unfold in it she
suggests that bacon was directing a
group of intellectuals who actually
wrote all the place Oh clever bacon but
the bacon theory falls completely into
madness when in 1888 Ignatius Donnelly
starts claiming that these found codes
inside the texts that's not all by the
way bacon according to Donnelly is also
Christopher Marlowe and Montaigne to
check out these two final lines from the
epilogue of The Tempest as you from
crimes would pardon'd be let your
indulgence set me free according to the
bacon Ian's these wines are actually an
anagram for tempest of Francis Bacon
Lord bear Illume do he narrow divulge me
words it is a shame that the literary
appears twice in the first lines and
three times in the second lines but no
problem say the bank owned Ian's just
pop it ' here and Bob's your uncle
apostrophes are so helpful like that but
the man who is more recently replaced
bacon as the lead contender the
protagonist of role Emmerich's film
anonymous Edward to bear the seventy
Earl of Oxford this theory was advanced
in two large books by Charlton awkward
and his wife this star of England and
the mysterious William Shakespeare are
the central arguments what the man from
Stratford couldn't possibly have had the
brain or the experience to write all
those plays only a lord could have
written them to Devere had the perfect
social background living for years in
Queen Elizabeth's court and three Devere
did not want his name to be known
because writing plays was considered a
vulgar pursuit for royalty and be the
play shows so much slimy and corrupt
royal behaviour that it would have just
totally blown up his spot and let's not
leave out the secret code take a look at
this line from act 1 scene 5 of him the
time is that of joint
Oh curse it sprite that ever I was born
to set it right what what oh oh no no no
no come on I what about the poem by Ben
Jonson entitled to the memory of my
beloved William Shakespeare in that
Johnson called Shakespeare the Swan a
babe ah ooh still to bear have property
on the Avon River I never mind that
Shakespeare was born and died in
stratford-on-avon this Jonson poem was
actually the preface to the first folio
which is the first time that all
Shakespeare's plays were collected in
one place in 1623 the folio was prepared
by John Hema jiz and Henry coda actors
who had worked with Shakespeare for 20
years and gave them repeated credit of
authors and never mind also the edward
de verre died in 1604 and a play like
The Tempest for example is clearly dated
to 1611 you know the Oxford Ian's have
an answer for that they have an answer
for everything
but each arm reaches further and further
out of its socket to find connections
that just don't exist and round and
round we go even Herman Melville and his
final book Billy Budd names the captain
of the ship indomitable Edward bear
Melville later said on that subject the
names of all fine authors are fictitious
ones simply standing as they do for the
mystical ever eluding spirit of all
beauty which ubiquitously possesses men
of genius but I think we shouldn't let
this make us complacent when it comes to
the smearing of shakespeare's name the
people who don't have as much craving
for conspiracy as roland emmerich won't
suddenly be turned by his movie but the
world is full of idiots it's full of
people sitting on their couches and
watching TV and watching the trailer
flicker by and saying to the other guy
on the couch I actually do you know
that's true he never did write those
plays there's like evidence there needs
to be some respect for human genius
especially when that genius comes from
simple beginnings because that is where
most
this comes from it comes from
Lincolnshire or the Bronx or it comes
from Liverpool or Stratford it grows at
a practice and it comes from the Stars
and I don't mean from aliens
Oh Roman I mean that a genius can be any
person who looks at a night sky full of
stars and never gets over it for the
rest of his life it is not in the Stars
to hold our destiny but in ourselves